قالت المتحدثه باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان روسيا تحتفظ بحق
اتخاذ اجراءات رد صارمه ضد ما وصفتها
بالهجمات الارهابيه الاوكرانيه على القرم
وعلى موسكو واضافت ان روسيا واثقه من وجود
دعم امريكي وبريطانيا للهجمات الاوكرانيه
التي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه في روسيا
بدا يستخدم على ارض المعركه القنابل
العنقوديه التي زودته بها الولايات
المتحده هذه القنابل استهدفت سياره
الصحفيين روس حيث قتل مراسل عسكري واوسبا
اخرون بجروح وعلى الرغم من تحضير المجتمع
الدولي ورؤساء عشرات الدول والمنظمات
الدوليه المعنيه من تزويدك بالقنابل
العنقوديه ما يعد خرقا للمعايير الانسانيه
اقدمت الولايات المتحده على ذلك ولن
يرضعها الا رد قاسي وملائم هجمته اوكرانيا
التي تستهدف البناء التحتيه الروسيه
مدعومه من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
والحديث عن السلام يبدا بوقف ضخ الاسلحه
في اوكرانيا